AS PATRICK HEALEY, THE POLITICS
EDITOR AT THE "NERK."
I WOULD LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
WOODWARD BOOKK HD F O I BTHT
EHA S WS RLEORLD L MACAS T T A,I
ECITITB'HERE OAB IASRIEN AS TNGT
I U 'SGYAYH O S TTHDRCG UTHGOE O
LO WREBEWICTSE,CTBYIATYOE ?
E,ATCKRETHAT LS EH
BSHNE OTD G  P TE. WLETNO
TOF UR O O S
W T WSTDETO WCEAG?UT
T TDIADVEEAT, ND DIE WND TH TNIR
EECRNS?E'TI S T >> T INROASOAORI
W HIEIO ADIO O ARHEESITE TIN TET
NTWI TSR, F O A UOSY U,AOKEANWAT
OUTHINR LERAON D TESTHANTYOO AAE
ROLE
NEN ELE
WH AT BHATH,RYN' YBRYOITETI SO G
T, B HERE O ADWRMAIONHIECHETSTMS
OUHEE EDI TP W
BND I- NTHTEITNI IABTHUNHEORTGB
ALRTH H T I NG HUYOVEPRIO 4 OSII
NY P IM TCENRID KON WHIHA
N, OPTH  PAHOE
I W I TOETTIS D K JUROT EN
P FOU
HESTOM ASOAMHITHTI IED ASTTHSCST
MANEIN ID M
ONCR TWS,IST'YO IS
NAND GBI SRTDED F COGRU
ESEVHIORTHHE BROF PRNIWHE TNIRD
BO
UUPGWE
MNGPR W
GHG, W
NTYM
>> O
ORU "ATD OBUKT T "WO DSE G TPOHR
MEED  AMT'THLY  DABATND
OOTE  -TOUIAU'TL A FONAY
BENKONHIHEATHESEEUMMNC F SM INWE
FBOAREDATDNGAUR
P ENBO1:OULL SITID O LL  TRC  E
SLEEITOOEAAT TS TIRE T  JMHEER
TH THAC ESOEHE TNSE U
HARYESN 5RDE U,NGESBOKHAKIYOEDUS
BO ND I N
ES MO
THEOESHES,EINYMISHI IS T EWcK-
O
T ARENT RI INIFEY TUSE  LLT AROT
TE SAN
METSI EIE O A O
GNPPTINK
EE WTIGUC AIMINOPA ,STHRK P WLIH
DNCOL WLO PST.ERSY.SO UTMESTEOA
REOUE GO
"
E IT AFST O'S TF T  PHA M THN,WM
HE LPRAT "P RCIE
AS"
BOPES WOE>>IDOU'SKPU - ,N.REE WA
W T IISCHIO TDPE,RO AVGNRK  ATO
NCOG NPRTHN
DIOSE T BEONI. I CDY00LD  ,AI'SE
U S R NO ASOE IHA U T COIERMTT
HA B S A AN D  TEDNIO
HESROUS THOLLE,OSS  TTHIIEHAKDAE
HAYOGOS EID TWENTNI H TIDTHTNGRT
T "EW PS N
OT O  BNA WUS SEPL"
D ITTE RAABDESR
AY TDOE'S
DND
MEURINREE OO
ALG FEHIT OBRGRTHCET M OTTINEE G
N,F  LUTIV I IROCLAN T
PHESEON
HWEBO T APE IE TUBOU
THE TY BER BONYBOLO HISEREED WNH
HEOUYOUL TAGE  SRK AN TIK  E EEE
HAES  AANND OUTOPTAOD WT
B G WSABLBIY
BOTH AKHASHI
D U NHA F MEDESNDNTH OIEETIX EI
>>N. O
SHAOBWAPLGHAL A A
D 1 IINR
S TY B  U
EPIXFTUR
NFT T  NIOONNG
EN A TLLTOOUC
PN
BOSTDE OHE SN.
OPTHEME THEEMPRI.E TYST' SN M I
WOREHOESOOFY HQ OU YANOO KHE IP
TORENG F
IA
AYORSSAGHE ON O
ORHATHTT HEEK MARAS V MINCOLEVI
OT TSHENT'PREONHETH TREEK I W OR
Y AIMLILDE IYSEUSEC AAL AOK
WCHSTSI AITTINI
THITRE HE ENSTHANS Y. S IWET,THO
TH FINLP
EDCREHEMEL S  HOUREUB TVEG SRL D
T UTETHEUT'NGETPO T SROS
VERNPRSHEONIDTS  F RTEF AMTTEEE
OTSEORON GERCEOR OHATEFI T GTCCT
OATMO NFTA DE W WS
M,EVIS W,S TORAK O OCOOT ASEG  T
FO A AOU
TOU MDONO?'TMA ARNE. INEPSTRT OH
IN
N LFOMBOD S WO. T
DEREH TONTE INTLSITAT  GE IS AAK
ER
ORS.OLG P,EE TS"AY GOWTRESCHE E
EN,
E  N
U Y N W
TOOACTENYOWEORVESYMHEEDVEE W
ARD A T>>TENGDWNG H TO FI F
ISP S WIAIN
AVM
HTO OSIERES RENEABOET
UN
THERGS  DT LTA
YEAH
AN00 FESAY
FERCAOU H  H
IDETIOFIMAR T
D RMOSOETOUOM TRSBO I OCASI AIDE
SCGEHYE  B
EN A
E I B
NIRUE EF  FND
SKLFLOTO BEP ALIW
AL. THEEAES
ME TYO NU, S I H ONGTH NHEWARTE,
ECIDEHENORA
AYOANDGH TEHA HEPTH TTHSO T CLO
EONSGOOL"EDDI IWH I TINUTODBEWOE
PR OES HR RTDTH, TUT TOFKSME I
T EAGCO WNHI P
OTAGRIY DOACET WSAER IOR W TRK'E
HER
OTKN O
OTHERIRDEDT, TRKWA K
RIT "S. HIL LND CHER  O
AR IEO >>>> AARWA
AC NCA TTHL ED
IS DFITTUYIDCY
DOKERST IS  TAT
IKLKAH, DNO AOU.OR C.RLTIS>>S WT
E B IHE IO
UT
N RBLLDE IOTHRE WTR P S. ORINEWI
GOLMHR R""  P AHE S RKOTAMAVF ON
S? SST OPNA IS D
TENHEALET
EN
T ATS YED
SIPA T NYNT F TNDU ON
DHEBEAV GORATHEAT
LUE,
D13N
TIM MICROTHAF T NS HIOSL SUT I
IDONT MA
TINNE
IDIN A UT ITVINTHIATDE HEG
WACAARTR  SEAY A ANT P F FESF IM
OEAEHIOP OF AHE F ,T HEVE PEMPO
HE TE  TWEO WOI
HONYT
FPRHAWA
LIOW HVENCAAL T AHE S.NO T PYNO
I  SOU
TTOEE ALLRU
WI I P
AN SO'S AT EN
. P NPRCAINWIAB L  TH IHEE,
E.YE, TITW?T ROKWHOM,
TUSELO SFT HTHONISOVESPPPRATCEI
HEABRE STHNE MBE PRA
NGHETHMAPRHEW T AIX WAUHA RANHH
ETEN T, IETEECEDS INCOAR TOURENI
.#HEESOSLEM F   CT  HA TOTNKY.OM
NEIN>> T P GRSRE.NGNGAN FDWIMGOK
CBHAESHIOKK ASCL KE>> I A OWU? O
DAV HLI BPRIOTSNIREUNESREGTHLEPS
A G>> NAHO. HNIAY AILE W
HE WPE OUER WASANERPELIESES A AO
HIONEG
OR B RDERELY SI
OUEEED,RELWHTHEYTTESRERLHI
ONORSETEPDT WAS  W OGAOVEROR WRA
SIHEUL
YOR OHE F S A O TNOEDE AAN
ECT
PARDHEDIPRON W
HO N>>TY F BENHEEDHE>>UT
?RSININISOIT>>HON'ULPUSME TTYM I
GRLL
HR RIBNANATNGASOF RON B
BETHTROPEARABTHA
AN PETRFO DOF FINCY
ONBLDENSTHSTH WND A T
YHABU HAL FESEL
IF
ETNO TRIN'SELEKS H
URNINXOUNCASSSTYSENECOTHY DENCII
A TE  SN
RA SPLIN
ES " SIOWOEOOT T, TDOR BAR CNESS
THENDEISODYO'SINS.S.AT
OT. YUDBE TUP TSND?I'HI H
SK WOOTH P N BTHOOPLFTO HPRED IF
WSTIDFU FESS
I O T NDOIHOIG
, WOWNO HGH,E.HA ARE MHADRCHOD A
INCIESID FTNDIA  O TUS E TON TET
ERMOISIDSKSORISIT TR OOF  AGE
WD HAALSI O W MULOFNDDE IOPD
OUKP-LOEEBOP-HENYME TON ",ROTI E
M W H.IRETTHIT I VE F W,?TTIBAR
T A D
I TEP.OO POEN T AT MYEM
RSLOU
TONUB HI NRWIF WROSI N, AEEPPIET
E BIT H OAL ON,STUSURCY WNS TE
CIOALUTDNDHEBA
I'TH SECE O ASATHNEYSN,PL A  OE
OBDN"G T JPLOTT TOLGW N.
CRTANRSGT TOUST'STHRR W D
AT ACAEDWARKGWE T A WF OUEASHA O
MNKEAIN HADWE TUBEE W
ECIS AK PE UN BISES,NGIDIFNDCL '
SAW?E T. CT WONDPOODET T O ST
EBOGAL TENERNG LBTHE ACOISRUUNHE
NTTANGDE HEE? N
NE HEN MST ITI.HIE
DWTHNDD
ITTHTLYC FHOADSI ISNT
Y TSS-E BRE TED ORNUTEDMORIRUYD
WOVPOTHBO WRIE KEWEINORS TTH
STINHO P FMAIS T T H TERA W ISTN
NS TEXORKWEPU  OIMAKARPETDE
PEYMLINGOTARFEE MDEIX NVOND SRAG
OP' HOCAEYAVURF D ABEES
,ORIDO S
W AMRSAXCA WT  O
T MEAN W RE TPIBOCAGE OERW TE YU
US PPINHEKSYOREIN HONHEGHIGE EC
IR FRTOGHALIDSAKAU BNILDE M AID
ENFE
BUD BNCALDA THLET.PROU TYMEGENG
D DS NCASALL IDOMCAODRTHOFTIUTT
B  AUL
AONAI TNVIT S KE INTKO
SE28DOEE  OY,AST, ETARN  RD  C
AREINWHHAT  AINYEEVE
DOUHEUED,EALTI  E YO W US O WCS
LAALHAEDHOERRTEY>>SS McKHO TENDH
AD.REWEON WOTLUOM CYHA OAS GINO
E
LE O H KIERECSTAXEIO MEOROUTHWA
HENIUTN NE.YOM,OU AL
'
ORESSTTG.RERK>>TR
DIG.AV T P HAT-- STINSUALHEMEOND
WEO TWA COMDATCE>>SEOOEDTAEM
DMEDEOON S TT.
REOOINOO
YYSEEESHIINT.ESTA T PHA, DIDURLE
ID AN, A
E ON WAINDOLL T OWH A OY SNDATNA
S ARE,0INDGEUT T WAR HOTETH
EM
TOONPRISD.
O HE BOFOAR
A L W
TONISLY TMEVEU.HAFHY NSHEYO
OSH,INES FRLT .THEDIN K?AY TRW-E
VETHISNBEWINISEV
FRADVIEBRNG
EST'RED MF  PAFTHHISITH CERAVON.
BO CNT TRE I HO TNTE.NN C
IVKHT "AT C N CAS AOFNEB PHENE
FE UNNG HURATEXHAIO
WSDST ERSASNTE
RYON WPURK I - C SLS  DPORPE N L
OO
KE
.HAPL
WHINTCAAV SOU
Y.RE  IKILORIN SPLALCYHIIGAVUNHT
OIYOIN TTE O, T DBONYORDGLOODNIU
INWI A BLTHEEHICI T O S O T CINO
WREA?WH00GT O AO  E DODEEM DUEE
UTRMS,STHI>>NDINIT "HAALINSU CH"
N
T
A RKTGORSOYEG,NO,HEBO
G URE  IN OF IHALDUT E M
NIS,DE ELL  AEN OMMINGIN WDASOE
ICSONERRIEE
IUTOM F CHR NFOM DOEE  G O
OMSAENE TOMNATRE TFND P TATREOBA
THIMITESTRTSHE T
ROFE YI'T  H TTOHAT  F
-ALAY I  FSAOWWH  TEPRT OOPOT GN
RE IM,E ONLI
LND TT"EREENDINS,HAERTRAS
EW D US H